My name is Jon Bristol, and I am the owner
of Super Fresh Detailing and Sanitation,
and we operate within Trinidad and Tobago.
In today's video, I will be cleaning
a three-piece microfiber couch set.
For this particular set,
the client was actually considering
replacing it completely
and getting a new one,
but they decided, since they were aware
of the cleaning services,
that they'd give it a try
to see if they could delay the purchase
just for a few more months.
Although this set looks like
it may be a leather set,
what you're actually
seeing is a lot of buildup
on the surface itself.
It is actually a microfiber couch,
which means we are able
to use our regular process
to get it cleaned.
This couch has never been
cleaned since it was bought.
In my experience, the microfiber
sets are usually dirtier
than other cotton or synthetic fibers.
Depending on the age of the
sofa and where it's located,
the buildup on it will
consist of different things.
Humid environments typically leave persons
with a lot more sweat on their skin,
which in turn ends up on the couch.
This is one of the dirtiest
couches I have encountered.
Currently looks dark brown,
with some areas being black.
Due to how soiled the couch was,
I spray on the Simple Green degreaser,
which works to break
down the dirt and oils,
and then wait 10 minutes for it to work
before I start scrubbing.
I generally apply the pre-spray evenly,
placing extra emphasis on the
areas that are more soiled.
I'm careful not to apply too much
to avoid overwetting the fabric
and to reduce the chances of splatter
once I start scrubbing.
Now that that 10-minute period has passed,
I can start scrubbing.
Scrubbing is that mechanical action
that helps break down the
larger pieces of debris
and makes everything ready
for extraction later on.
Using a variable-speed polisher
with a brush attachment,
I begin scrubbing,
starting at the crevices
and working my way to the
flatter portions of the surface.
In this case, I have
to make multiple passes
with the machine as well
as scrubbing and spraying.
After scrubbing, once I see that the soils
have sufficiently been broken down,
I move on to the actual extraction.
Here, our equipment sprays in a solution
of clean water, fabric
shampoo, and deodorizer
and vacuums at the same time.
This means that the debris
that is on the surface of the couch
is rinsed away with every
pass of our machine.
Taking the couch panel by panel,
I start at the edges,
where the crevices are,
and work my way over the smoother areas.
I'm also careful to make multiple passes
where the couch was most soiled.
After cleaning the loveseat
and consulting the owner,
I can now move on to the rest of the set.
Because of the condition
of the wastewater,
I'll make extra passes on this couch set
to ensure that we get all of the dirt out.
The most difficult thing about cleaning
this couch in particular
is the amount of time that it's taking.
This couch took between
five and six hours to clean.
Now that I'm finished cleaning,
this set is going to be damp to the touch.
However, it's only going to
be about three to four hours
for it to be fully dry
and ready to use again.
A yearly cleaning would ensure that
the dust, dirt, sweat, as
well as other contaminants
don't have the opportunity
to significantly build up on your sofa
and affect the air quality and
overall hygiene in your home.
After the process of cleaning this couch,
the natural light brown has been restored.
The clients were really
satisfied with the end result,
and they were able to delay
purchasing an entire new set for a while.